you remember I brought this up to Paul  he didn't remember you brought me to the  uh recording once uh with I did a  Tenenbaum I can't remember uh we did war  machine yeah my singing in that yeah  make it on the album you better watch  out cause I'm a war machine yeah but I'm  singing on it am I on the album that's  correct wow are you you're are you lying  nope play that song War Machine  [Music]  if you hear me  wait till you  it's me he's in there  that's me  [Music]  war machine wow that's me that is do the  other members of the band ever get upset  that you brought people into the studio  to record at first but then they heard  me sing and I realized it was worth it